-Welcome back to the show,
everybody.
You know, not a lot of things
are certain in this crazy world.
We scurry through life
lickety-split
from one fleeting experience
to another.
Nothing seems sacred anymore.
Nothing seems permanent.
And that's why this week at
"The Tonight Show,"
we're saluting the one thing we
know is still permanent --
the permanent,
a.k.a. the permanent wave,
a.k.a. the perm.
That's right --
it's time for the return of
"Tonight Show Perm Week."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ It's Perm Week ♪
♪ On the "Fallon" show ♪
♪ It's Perm Week ♪
♪ Oh, my God ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-This is
"Tonight Show Perm Week,"
the very special week where,
every day,
we pick someone
from our audience
and stylishly perm their hair.
Tonight's lucky perm recipient
is Alyssa Mancuso.
Alyssa is 25 years old.
She's from the Poconos,
and she's very excited about
her new hairdo.
It's been a big day for Alyssa.
Take a look.
-Hi. My name is Alyssa Mancuso,
and today, I'm getting a perm.
I don't know if I have the
bone structure for a perm.
I guess we'll find out.
-We're Alyssa's friends.
-And we're excited to see
her perm.
-So, I really don't think
Alyssa's done, like,
anything crazy with her hair.
-I have never done anything
crazy with my hair.
This will be the craziest thing
I've ever done.
This is how it's been.
I was born with the bangs.
-I'm very curious to see how
the bangs look.
-Like, I've only seen perms
in the movies,
and I didn't know
that people still got perms.
-I want to feel like
my hair bounces when I walk.
I feel like that would be fun.
-Someone we hope she won't look
like is Little Orphan Annie.
It's very tight
and very high up.
I think that's the worst way
this could go.
-All my life, I was known as
the girl with the bangs,
and now, good or bad, I will be
known as the girl with the perm.
Maybe I'll look really great and
I'll be a perm girl from now on.
-Yeah. Yeah.
Maybe you will
look really great.
I think you will.
Now, Alyssa has been sequestered
since she got permed,
so she hasn't seen herself yet.
And her friends
haven't seen her either.
This entire process
has been cloaked in secrecy.
We've got her friends
right here.
Say hello, guys. How are you?
-Good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I like when we interviewed
you before,
you said, "We're Alyssa's
friends" at the same time.
Are you excited to see
what she looks like?
-Yes.
-Wow. You really are
like a band almost.
Alright, now,
don't remove the blindfolds
until I tell you, please.
Audience, are you ready for the
brand-new,
freshly permed Alyssa?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Here is Alyssa before.
[ Drumroll ]
And here she is now.
Alyssa, come on out!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Oh, my God ♪
-Wow. Whoa! Wow.
Wow! They gave you some frizz.
They gave you some -- Wow!
They gave her some extra frizzle
in the front there.
They really -- It's cute.
It's really cute.
You look great.
-I love a little extra frizzle,
you know?
-Yeah, you look cute. Yeah.
Alright, guys, it's time.
Are you ready to see Alyssa?
-Yeah.
-Oh, wow.
Alright, hold hands
and follow me over here.
Okay, here we come.
Alright.
On the count of three,
take off your blindfolds.
One, two, three.
[ Drumroll ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Oh, my God ♪
-That's not a great --
-The look of horror!
-The look of horror.
-You guys have
never been less supportive.
-Yes, that was
terrible reaction.
You should have been like,
"Yeah, wow!"
-Oh, my gosh! Whoa!
-No, you can't redo
the reaction.
It's real.
I think you look gorgeous.
-Thank you. There's one.
-Now, for the most important
reveal of all, Alyssa,
are you ready to see yourself?
-No, not at all.
[ Drumroll ]
-You have to.
-Not at all.
-Three, two, one, reveal.
-♪ Oh, my God ♪
-What are you talking about?
-Oh, my God.
-This is not
what I thought it would be.
-Yes, it is!
This is exactly --
You look great.
How long are you gonna keep it?
-I don't know.
Our thanks to the
Randy Darden hair salon
for this wonderful perm.
Happy Perm Week, everyone.
-Oh, my God.
-We'll be right back with
Super Bowl champion
Travis Kelce.
-♪ It's Perm Week ♪
♪ On the "Fallon" show ♪
♪ It's Perm Week ♪
♪ Oh, my God ♪